.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Hast du das gesehen?
"Müdigkeitserkennung".
Vielleicht
hat er deine Augenringe gesehen.
Das könnte sein.
Wann bist du heute aufgestanden?
- Um 3 Uhr.
Um 3 Uhr morgens? Warum so früh?
Ich musste kochen.
Und das Essen ausliefern.
Wenig Schlaf und ständig unterwegs -
das ist das Leben
von Sasikumar Tharmalingam.
Als Hindupriester in der Schweiz
ist er ein vielgefragter Mann.
* Sanfte Glockentöne, Gesang *
Mit einem Gebet schickt er heute
die Seele eines verstorbenen Mannes
auf die Reise ins Jenseits.
Vor 40 Jahren
brach in Sri Lanka Krieg aus.
Er trieb Tamilen in die Flucht.
Heute leben rund 60'000 Tamilinnen
und Tamilen in der Schweiz.
10'000 sind pensioniert.
Sie wünschen sich
ein Leben und Sterben in Würde
und nach hinduistischen Traditionen.
Das steht in Konflikt mit den
hiesigen Angeboten und den Gesetzen.
Als Hindupriester und Brückenbauer
kämpft Sasikumar für die Anliegen
der tamilischen Diaspora.
Mit 14 flüchtete Sasikumar
allein in die Schweiz.
Seither
bestimmt eine Frage sein Leben:
Wie gelingt der Spagat
zwischen Integration und Bewahrung?
Integration bedeutet nicht,
dass man seine Identität verliert.
Integration bedeutet für mich
miteinander zusammenzuleben.
Dass wir uns an die Umgebung,
in der wir leben, anpassen.
Aber nicht, dass wir
unsere Identität ganz verlieren.
Auch der Tod und die Bestattung sind
Teil einer gelungenen Integration.
Lange mangelte es hier in der Schweiz
an den Voraussetzungen
für traditionell
hinduistische Bestattungen.
Erst vor vier Jahren wurde
auf dem Bremgartenfriedhof Bern
der europaweit erste Hindualtar
auf einem öffentlichen Friedhof
errichtet.
Viele fragten uns,
warum sie den Sarg ihres Vaters
oder ihrer Mutter verbrennen
und die Asche dann nach Indien
oder Sri Lanka bringen müssen.
"Wir brauchen einen Ort,
um uns an sie erinnern zu können."
Das hier war eine gute Lösung,
auch für die nächste Generation.
Wenn sie hier
das Abschiedsfest gemacht haben,
können sie diesen Tempel
auch ab und zu besuchen.
* Trauergesang *
Im Hinduismus werden die Verstorbenen
eingeäschert und im Wasser bestattet.
So wird die Seele reingewaschen.
Diese Praktik ist für Hindus heilig -
doch in der Schweiz
praktisch überall verboten.
Die Eltern der jüngeren Generationen
haben 30, 40 Jahre hier gelebt.
Wenn jemand in Zürich lebt, sagt er:
"Der Limmatplatz
ist für mich heilig."
Oder wer in Basel lebt, sagt,
der Rheinfluss sei für ihn heilig.
Wir wollen nicht, dass unsere Eltern
30, 40 Jahre hier leben
und wir sie dann an einen
unbekannten Ort am Ganges bringen.
Nach eidgenössischer
Wasserschutzverordnung
ist das Beigeben von Asche
eine Verunreinigung der Gewässer.
Vor drei Monaten reichte Sasikumar
beim Kanton Bern
ein Bewilligungsgesuch ein.
Jetzt heisst es warten.
5 Uhr morgens in Kerzers bei Bern.
Frau und Kinder
sind meist noch am Schlafen,
wenn der 48-jährige Schweizer
das Haus verlässt.
Oben beim Altar
habe ich zwei Fotos gesehen. - Ja.
Darf ich fragen, wer das ist?
- Mein Vater und meine Mutter.
Mein Vater
ist im Krieg gestorben.
Nach dem Tod meines Vaters hat
meine Mutter alles allein gemacht.
Ja. Und jetzt ...
Meine Mutter hat rund zehn Jahre
mit mir in der Schweiz gelebt.
2013 nahm sie Abschied.
* Ruhige Musik *
Dein Vater ist im Krieg gestorben.
- Ja.
Hat er gekämpft?
Nein, er hat nicht gekämpft.
Er wurde auf dem Nachhauseweg
von seiner Arbeit ...
... also ...
Er wurde mit einer Bombe ermordet.
- Ja.
Genau.
Ja.
Wie alt warst du?
Hm! Damals war ich ...
... ungefähr sieben Jahre alt.
Es ist schwierig.
Wenn ich darüber spreche, kommt ...
... alles raus.
- Mhm.
Darum spreche ich nicht oft darüber.
Mhm.
Raum für Trauer blieb wenig.
Als ältester Bruder
von drei Schwestern
musste er
früh Verantwortung übernehmen.
Kommt dir gerade eine spontane
Kindheitserinnerung in den Sinn?
Wenn du so einkaufst?
Ja. Also ...
Also, während ...
Während der Kriegszeit ...
Ich habe einfach ...
Ich brachte die Kokosnüsse
und Früchte, die bei uns wuchsen,
auf einen Frischmarkt.
Ich versuchte, die zu verkaufen,
und mit diesem Geld kaufte ich Reis.
Wenn ich einkaufe,
kommt sofort diese Erinnerung auf,
wie ich das gemacht habe. Genau.
Auch heute kümmert sich der Koch
v.a. um andere.
Tagsüber
in seinem ayurvedischen Restaurant,
danach im Tempel
oder in den Stuben seiner Landsleute.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Seine Mutter sah ihren
heranwachsenden Sohn in Gefahr
und entschied deshalb,
ihn mit 14 Jahren
allein auf die Flucht zu schicken.
Die Frage war, wann ich
meine Familie wiedersehen werde.
Z.B. meine Schwestern.
Ich sollte einfach weggehen.
Wir hatten nichts geplant.
Ich hatte nicht geplant,
in die Schweiz zu kommen.
Meine Mutter berührte meinen Kopf
und meine Füsse und sagte:
"Ich schliesse meine Liebestür."
"Ich gebe dir den Schlüssel."
"Wenn wir uns wiedersehen,
öffnest du diese Tür wieder."
"Bis dann
bleibt mein Herz wie ein Stein."
Zwölf Jahre musste er warten, bis er
seine Mutter wiedersehen konnte.
Er strandete in einer
Flüchtlingsunterkunft im Emmental,
fern ab von allem,
was er bisher kannte.
Für die Schule war er zu alt,
um zu arbeiten zu jung.
Wie viele Tamilen fand er später
einen Job in der Gastronomie
und fand so zu seiner Leidenschaft,
dem Kochen.
Heute ist das Haus der Religionen
in Bern Sasikumars Lebensmittelpunkt.
Hier führt er
sein Restaurant Vanakam,
gleich daneben steht der Hindutempel,
den er
mit Freunden ins Leben gerufen hat.
Sie störten sich daran, dass
nach alter hinduistischer Tradition
nur Männer aus der richtigen Kaste
das Priesteramt ausüben dürfen.
Nach dem Studium
der heiligen Schriften
und der Konsultation
ihres Gurus in Indien
fassten sie den mutigen Entschluss,
ihren eigenen Reformtempel
zu gründen.
Hier gilt
das traditionelle Kastensystem nicht.
Das Priesteramt
steht allen Frauen und Männern offen
und die Gebete
werden nicht in Sanskrit,
sondern auf Tamilisch gesprochen.
Sasi ...
- Ja?
Der Weg zur Reformation:
War der einfach oder schwierig?
Wie sahen die Reaktionen
auf diese Idee aus?
Es war ein sehr schwieriger Weg.
Wir haben auch
sehr viel Kritik erlebt, weltweit.
Manchmal waren wir in Lebensgefahr.
Das kann man so sagen.
Wenn ich das in Sri Lanka
oder Indien präsentiere,
ist es noch schwieriger.
Aber auch hier in Europa
war es nicht so einfach.
Ganz am Anfang
war es sehr schwierig.
Aber jetzt gewinnen wir viele Leute
aus der zweiten Generation.
Sie akzeptieren diese Reformation
und lieben das auch.
Heute bereiten er und sein Team
eine Hochzeit für 600 Gäste vor.
Was gibt das?
- Das ist ...
Wir glauben,
dass Gott nicht nur Form,
sondern auch Formloses ist.
Aber dieses Formlose ...
... ist Energie.
Darum machen wir
eine Darstellung davon.
Die Schnur rundherum
ist unser Nervensystem,
mit den 72'000 Nadis.
Die Kokosnuss
ist sozusagen unser Kopf.
Die fünf Mangoblätter
sind die Augen, Ohren, die Nase -
unsere fünf Sinne.
Das ist eine Darstellung des Kosmos.
Sie schwören in Anwesenheit
dieses Allerheiligen,
dass die Eheschliessung
zusammen stattfindet.
Die Ehe hat in der tamilischen Kultur
einen hohen Stellenwert.
Traditionell bestimmen die Eltern
in Berücksichtigung
der Kastenzugehörigkeit,
wer wen heiratet.
Die junge Generation,
die hier aufgewachsen ist,
fordert mehr Selbstbestimmung.
Der Reformtempel zieht Heiratswillige
aus der ganzen Schweiz an.
* Dynamische Musik *
* Ruhige Musik *
* Ritueller Gesang *
* Glocken *
Ich muss kurz oben parkieren
und die Asche holen.
Die habe ich vergessen.
Was ist das für eine Asche?
Was bringt diese Asche?
Das ist die heilige Asche,
die man ... - Aha, nicht von ...
Wenn ich Besuche mache,
mache ich das als Segen.
Aha, keine Asche von ...
- Nein.
Die erste Flüchtlingsgeneration
bestand v.a. aus tamilischen Männern.
Sie gingen von einem kurzen Krieg
und einer raschen Rückkehr aus.
Darum blieben sie
in der Schweiz oft unter sich.
Wie geht es diesen Menschen
40 Jahre später?
Der ersten Generation?
Denen, die ...
Ich sehe viele,
die sehr früh sterben.
Denn sie haben mit 65, 67
schon viele Krankheiten.
Ja.
- Und wenn ich die Ursache suche:
schlechte Ernährung ...
... oder sehr lange Arbeitszeiten.
- Ja.
Sie haben sehr, sehr viele
anstrengende Jobs gemacht.
Und mit den damaligen Bewilligungen
durften sie zehn Jahre lang
nicht aus der Schweiz ausreisen.
Viele sind auch Alkoholiker.
Sie sind ganz allein
und haben keine Beschäftigung.
Sie haben Heimweh.
- Mhm.
Ich weiss von jemandem,
der verheiratet war
und drei Kinder hatte:
zwei, drei und vier Jahre alt.
Er wollte die Familie
in die Schweiz bringen,
musste aber wegen der Bewilligung
10-15 Jahre warten.
Als er seine Familie
nach 15 Jahren wiedersah,
hatten die Kinder fast
keine Verbindung mehr zum Vater.
All das wurde nie aufgearbeitet.
Sie kriegten hier keine Therapie
oder auch nur
irgendwelche Unterstützung.
Das sind alles Ursachen dafür,
dass manchmal ...
Ich sehe viele Familien, in denen
die Männer schwere Alkoholiker sind.
Und gewalttätig.
Das ist alles da.
Aber wenn ich
ihren Hintergrund verstehe,
sprich, warum sie das machen,
möchte ich ihnen helfen.
Heute leben in der Schweiz
über 10'000 pensionierte Tamilinnen
und Tamilen.
Traditionell kümmern sich in
Sri Lanka die Kinder um ihre Eltern.
Die Realität in der Schweiz
sieht oft anders aus.
Darum häufen sich für Sasikumar
Besuche in Altersheimen.
I can't speak Deutsch.
I only know English.
That's why I learn more Deutsch.
Frau Sarojinidevi ist 74-jährig.
1991 kam sie als Witwe
mit zwei Töchtern in die Schweiz.
* Tamilisch *
Ich habe keine Arbeit.
Ich sitze nur rum.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie den Teppich
unter die Füsse.
Das ist lieb, danke.
Wie geht es Ihnen
hier im Altersheim?
Es ist schwierig.
Das Einzige, was mir gut gefällt,
ist, dass ich immer
einen Arzt rufen kann.
Ja.
- Aber sonst ...
Ich vermisse das tamilische Essen.
Ich vermisse die Sprache.
Wenn ich mit anderen Tamilinnen
zusammen wäre,
könnten wir
schöne Erinnerungen austauschen.
Hier habe ich keine Freunde.
* Tamilisch *
Ihr grösster Schmerz:
der Verlust ihres Sohnes.
Mit 21 ist er im Krieg gefallen.
Das Schicksal von Frau Sarojinidevi
teilen viele tamilische Eltern.
Um ihr Leid zu lindern und ihnen
ein Altern mit Würde zu ermöglichen,
planen Sasikumar und seine Leute ein
Wohnheim für Tamilinnen und Tamilen.
* Ruhiger Gesang *
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Tempel
gibt es heute Anlass zum Feiern.
Das Bewilligungsgesuch für
Wasserbestattungen wurde angenommen.
Das Recht
auf eine schickliche Bestattung
sei in diesem Fall
höher zu gewichten
als das Wasserschutzgesetz.
Sasikumar und sein Team
ehren heute Menschen,
die sie
auf dem Weg unterstützt haben.
Unsere gesetzlichen Grundlagen
basieren auf einer Gesellschaft,
die so nicht mehr existiert.
Gerade im Bereich Religion:
Wir haben keine einzige
gesetzliche Grundlage,
die sich auf andere
Religionsgemeinschaften bezieht.
Wir sprechen hier
nicht von Asylsuchenden,
sondern von Bürgerinnen und Bürgern.
Viele sind hier aufgewachsen
und leben seit 25 Jahren hier.
Ein Abend zu Hause
mit seiner Familie:
eher selten.
Seit 23 Jahren ist Sasikumar
mit seiner Ehefrau Sangeetha
verheiratet.
Ihre Tochter ist 21,
ihr Sohn 18 Jahre alt.
* Tamilisch *
Ist das eure Hochzeit?
- Unsere Hochzeit. Genau.
Mein Bruder
hat so viel Gutes über Sasi erzählt.
Für mich war er ein Held.
In meiner Jugend.
Es war von Anfang an
eine gewünschte Hochzeit.
Oder wie sagt man?
Also, von euch gewünscht
oder von den Eltern?
Von allen.
* Tamilisch *
Tochter Samjugtha
arbeitet als Kleinkinderzieherin,
Sohn Haryram macht die Ausbildung
zum Naturheilpraktiker.
Wie viele
tamilische Kinder in der Schweiz,
haben sie nebst der Grundschule
am Wochenende die tamilische
Sprach- und Kulturschule besucht.
Der Vater isst mit den Händen
und die Kinder mit Messer und Gabel.
Ist das der Generationenunterschied?
- Ich esse lieber mit den Händen.
Es schmeckt einfach besser.
Aber meine Nägel ...
- Frisch gemacht?
Wenn man die Nägel macht
und dann Curry isst,
sind sie immer gelb.
Und ich habe keine Lust,
sie dann neu zu machen.
Aber ich denke, die meisten Tamilen
sind meiner Meinung:
Tamilisches Essen
ist einfach besser mit den Händen.
* Tamilisch *
Fühlt ihr euch komplett frei
in der Partnerwahl?
Also, was Kultur und Religion angeht?
Oder wie ist das bei euch?
Ich möchte jemand Tamilisches.
- Ja.
Einfach wegen der Kultur.
Damit ich mich wohler fühle.
Oder?
Und ... Ja, deswegen.
- Ja.
Aber wer das wird, ist uns von der
Erziehung her selbst überlassen.
Mhm.
Mir ist es schon wichtig,
dass mein zukünftiger Partner
ein Tamil ist.
Weil ich einfach gerne
dieselben Werte und Normen pflege.
Damit man eben auch zusammen
in den Tempel geht.
Damit man die Witze versteht.
Und eben auch die gleiche Sicht
auf die Kultur hat.
Ich denke, dass ich mich so
einfach wohler fühle.
Als Eltern haben wir die Erwartung,
ein Mitspracherecht zu haben.
Und ...
Es gibt
sicher auch Diskussionen darüber.
Aber im Vordergrund
stehen die Bedürfnisse der Kinder.
Ihre Erwartungen
sind auch für mich sehr wichtig.
Auf all meine Fragen
hat Sasikumar eine Antwort bereit.
Unerklärt bleibt für mich,
wie er mit seinem Mammutprogramm
und so wenig Schlaf zurechtkommt.
Wie kommt er mit so wenig Schlaf aus?
Was denkt ihr?
Ich verstehe das auch nicht.
Er kommt relativ spät nach Hause.
Heute war er früh hier.
Das ist eigentlich nicht so gesund.
Ich frage mich auch, wie er
das macht. Ich könnte das nicht.
* Tamilisch *
Ich weiss, dass das wichtig
für meine Gesundheit ist.
Ich müsste besser darauf achten.
Die Kinder machen auch immer Druck,
dass ich mehr schlafen müsse.
Ich versuche das in der Zukunft.
Okay? Ist gut?
- Ja, ja.
* Tamilisch *
Und dann ruft die Pflicht.
Zur späten Stunde
rückt der Vater nochmals aus:
Ein 80-jähriger Tamile liegt
in kritischem Zustand im Spital.
Dass der Seelsorger
auch ausserhalb der Besuchszeiten
Eintritt in Schweizer Heime
oder Spitäler erhält,
war lange nicht selbstverständlich.
Ein Mann hatte eine Herzkrankheit
und hatte nicht mehr lange zu leben.
Seine Töchter wollten unbedingt,
dass ich dabei bin.
Und er wollte
diese spirituellen Lieder hören.
Ich kam ungefähr um 1 Uhr an.
Aber damals kannten sie uns
im Spital noch nicht.
Und ich hatte keinen Badge.
Oder sonst irgendeinen Beweis.
Nur meinen Ausweis.
Sie sagten mir einfach,
Besuche seien
erst am nächsten Tag wieder erlaubt.
Das gehe einfach nicht so.
Grüezi.
- Grüezi.
Ich bin hinduistischer Seelsorger
und habe einen Termin
mit einem Patienten in Gebäude N263.
Sie können einen der Lifte nehmen.
- Danke.
Die Zusammensetzung der Schweizer
Bevölkerung hat sich verändert,
und damit auch die Nachfrage
nach Seelsorgenden.
2018 bot die Universität Bern
erstmals einen Studiengang
für religiöse Begleitung
im Migrationskontext an.
Zu den ersten Diplomierten
gehörte auch Sasikumar.
Vor 20 Jahren
konnte ich mir nicht vorstellen,
so einen Spitalbesuch zu machen.
Ich hatte auch den Mut dazu nicht.
Also, kein Vertrauen.
"Dürfen wir so etwas
überhaupt verlangen?"
Das ist für uns auch sehr neu.
Wir merken jetzt,
dass es wichtig ist,
professionelle Seelsorge
anbieten zu können.
Und v.a. im Spital
ist das auch sehr notwendig.
Wenn jemand z.B.
in einer Notsituation ist.
Es ist wichtig,
dass sie dieselbe Sprache sprechen
und sie so ihre Gefühle
direkt ausdrücken können.
Das ist sehr wichtig.
- Ja.
* Tamilisch *
Solche Besuche
leistete er früher ehrenamtlich.
Heute werden er und andere
nicht-christliche Seelsorgende
dafür bezahlt.
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Haus der Religionen
findet heute ein Gedenktag statt.
An die 40-jährige Fluchtgeschichte
der tamilischen Bevölkerung.
Organisiert
hat ihn die junge Generation,
die damit zeigen möchte,
dass Sie das Schicksal der Flücht-
lingsgeneration nicht vergessen hat.
(TV) Die Abstimmung, provoziert
durch die nationale Aktion,
geht zu Ungunsten der Flüchtlinge
aus.
Die Stimmung in Bern
ist gegen die Tamile.
Wenn sie schon kommen,
sollen sie selber schauen.
Das ist nicht Amerika.
Die Schweiz ist zu klein.
Tagediebe.
Laavanja Sinnadurai
hat den Event mit organisiert.
Wir haben
nur gutes Feedback gekriegt.
Wie Sasikumar engagiert sie sich
in der tamilischen Diaspora
als Mediatorin
und interkulturelle Vermittlerin.
Dieses Bild gefällt mir am besten.
Wir haben es für den Flyer benutzt.
Wir als zweite Generation
haben eher gelernt, Nein zu sagen.
Wenn es zu viel ist, ist es zu viel.
Das wird in der ersten Generation
als unfreundlich gesehen.
Ich sage ihm immer,
er solle seine Kräfte sparen
und wirklich nur dort
zum Einsatz kommen ...
Er muss mit seinen Ressourcen
sparsam umgehen,
sonst brennt er aus.
Die erste Generation
hat dann einfach keine Kraft mehr.
Da sind wir manchmal ...
- Das ist ein Streitpunkt.
Genau. Also, ich lege ihm das
einfach ans Herz.
Aber dieses Auf-die-Zähne-beissen,
wie es Sasi macht,
dieses Sich-nicht-abgrenzen:
Ist das etwas Tamilisches?
Und die Schweizer Werte sind dann,
sich abzugrenzen?
Oder ...
- Ja. - Ja.
Er war als Jugendlicher
in einem Asylzentrum.
Was er alles gesehen hat,
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Und ich war hier im Niederscherli
mit meinen Eltern.
Ich bin wie ein Küken, ganz weich.
Und er
wurde ins kalte Wasser geworfen.
Das sind zwei unterschiedliche
Ausgangspunkte.
Du hast Konflikte zwischen
den Generationen angesprochen.
Was sind die grössten Konflikte?
Welche Themen
kommen immer wieder auf?
Ich kam mal mit einem Thema ...
Das ist noch ein Tabuthema
in der tamilischen Gesellschaft.
In einer interkulturellen
Vermittlung hatte ich einen Jungen,
der sich
als homosexuell geoutet hatte.
Dann ging ich zu Sasi und fragte:
"Du bist so offen, würdest du
ein homosexuelles Paar trauen?"
Da hörte ich erst mal: "Nein."
Mhm.
- Das ist der aktuelle Stand.
Ja. - Das sind Fragen,
die unsere Generation betreffen.
Ja.
Ich brauche ein bisschen Zeit.
- Mhm. Eben, genau.
Du sagtest mit deiner Reformation
Nein zum Kastensystem. - Ja.
Aber ich könnte kritisch sagen,
dass es auch ein Kastensystem ist,
wenn du Homosexuellen
nicht dieselben Rechte zusprichst.
Du sagst:
"Ihr seid nicht gleich viel wert."
Ich schätze die menschlichen Werte
sehr.
Jeder Mensch auf dieser Welt
hat das Recht,
so zu leben,
wie es für ihn richtig ist.
Von der religiösen Sicht her
nehmen wir die Menschen so an,
wie sie sind.
Ich bin bereit, das zu akzeptieren.
Warum
haben sie nicht dieselben Rechte?
Wenn du mich fragst,
ob ich das Ritual durchführe -
dazu bin ich noch nicht bereit.
Also, die Reformation
braucht noch etwas Zeit.
Im Moment bin ich nicht bereit dazu.
Die 33-jährige Bernerin war als Kind
oft mit ihren Eltern im Tempel.
Die Räume sind für sie
eine Art zweite Heimat.
Besteht ein Druck von der
ersten Generation auf die zweite,
dass ihr bestimmte Dinge
bewahren müsst?
Ja, das beginnt bei der Hochzeit.
Man muss heiraten, man muss
in dem und dem Alter heiraten.
Als Frau ist man Kulturträgerin.
Jungs werden weniger kontrolliert.
Tamilische Frauen
sind eher unter sozialer,
gesellschaftlicher Kontrolle.
Ich versuche, das zu brechen:
"Come on, wir sind in der Schweiz."
Es kann nicht sein,
dass der ältere Bruder Mist baut
und die jüngere Schwester
nicht raus darf.
Das geht für mich nicht auf.
Ich hoffe, dass sie sich auch
für die jungen Frauen einsetzen.
Denn ich bin dran mit meiner Arbeit.
Ich habe z.B. einen Fall
mit einem tamilischen Mädchen,
das einen Freund hat.
Dann wurde sie fremdplatziert,
weil es zu Hause nicht mehr ging.
Ich habe mit den Eltern gesprochen
und dann heisst es:
"Sie wollen uns sagen, wie wir
unsere Tochter erziehen sollen?"
"S i e ?" So klingt es dann.
Aber das Kindeswohl
war nicht gewährleistet,
darum
musste sie fremdplatziert werden.
Dass Sinnadurai Brücken baut
zwischen der tamilischen
und schweizerischen Kultur,
verdankt sie mitunter
Sasikumars Offenheit.
Er ist sehr wichtig für uns,
für die zweite Generation.
Mit seiner offenen Art ...
Er sagt nicht: "So ist es."
Er sagt: "Es ist so, weil ..."
Er erklärt und ist auch offen
für neue Argumente.
Das schätze ich enorm.
Sonst wäre ich nicht hier und würde
keine solche Veranstaltung machen.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Dann ist es so weit: Im Dezember 2023
kann Sasikumar die erste offizielle
Wasserbestattung durchführen.
* Ritueller Gesang *
Das kantonale Amt
für Wasser und Abfälle
hat grosse Zugeständnisse gemacht:
Nebst der Asche dürfen ein Teelöffel
Milch und einzelne Rosenblätter
in die Aare gegeben werden.
Und: Maximal 20 Wasserbestattungen
pro Jahr sind erlaubt.
Damit ist klar:
Für Sasikumar ist die
heutige Bestattung eine Genugtuung,
aber sein Einsatz geht weiter.
Damit Tamilinnen und Tamilen
in der Schweiz
würdevoll
leben, altern und sterben können.
* Ritueller Gesang *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024